Speaker 1: Let's go next to Paul
Garcia from Mexico. Welcome, Paul.
Speaker 3: Hi, David. Can you hear me?
Speaker 1: I can hear you fine.
Speaker 3: Oh, okay. And go into going back
to the Andrew Yang third party proposal. Yeah,
you remember it? Of course. What would you like
to see? What would impress you from third party?
Speaker 1: Well, I would like to see a third
party that's to the left of the Democratic Party,
but not made up of people who are cuckoo for
Cocoa Puffs like the Green Party. That's what
I would like to see. I would like to see an
actual socially Democratic Party that's to
the left of the Democratic Party.
Speaker 3: Could they be like
if in the third party, god power, you know, in
there in the U.S.? Yes. I didn't know the if
or something in the future. Right. Yep. Could they
do like direct voting on on issues like, you know,
because he talk about general consensus,
ease and stuff like that. Right. Yeah.
Andrea, I am so glad they both passed. Like, do
you want this or that and talk about National?
Speaker 1: Well, that's not really a question
about third parties. It's just a question of how
our political system works. I mean, are you saying
if you had members of this imaginary third party
in the Senate? Is that what you're saying?
Speaker 3: Yeah. Could they be could they do
that behind reform? Or if they were.
Speaker 1: In the Senate, they would
get a vote? I mean, I think I might be
misunderstanding your question, but wherever
these third party candidates were elected, they
would be able to vote and influence policy,
whether it's the House or the Senate or if you
had a governor or whatever the case may be. I
apologize if I'm misunderstanding the question.
Speaker 3: No, I think you're getting it
right. Okay. I think it would be like a
constitutional change, I guess my question.
Speaker 1: Yeah, the constitutional change might
be required to get the third parties elected
the way things are going. But I have I have clips
about how third parties could could make inroads.
But that's its own complicated reality as well.
Speaker 3: Yeah. Yeah. Thank you.
Speaker 1: Paul, what part of Mexico are you in?
Speaker 3: She won't. Last time I was, I was here.
I told you it was kind of getting chilly. Yeah,
you were like, how cold is it? And I was like,
I don't know, minus five or something. Is
it like, well, that's barely getting cold,
but have you ever been in a dry, cold air?
Speaker 1: Dry, cold air? I,
I guess I don't know.
Speaker 3: This invasion is
completely different here in the cold. I know
you're. You're in near New York, right? Yeah.
So you you get really cold winters. Yes. But
I mean, in the U.S., in humid regions, in -17.
Celsius. Yes. Feels like minus ten here. I swear.
Speaker 1: Well, I believe it. I believe it.
What's the elevation where you are? Do you know?
Speaker 3: It's around 2000 meters.
Speaker 1: 2000 meters. Oh, wow.
And are you completely acclimated to it?
It feels fine. No headaches, nothing.
Speaker 3: I'm from a small
town. I live now, and a CD
here is like one 1400. My town is two 200.
2200. So it's it's it feels the change. You
feel it when you go back and forth.
Speaker 1: I bet. I bet. All right,
Paul. Well, thank you for the call.
Speaker 3: Thank you, too. All right.
Speaker 1: A beautiful phone call from our
friendly neighbors to the south in Mexico,
where I hope to return very, very soon, folks.
That does it for calls today. My apologies.
I throw myself at the mercy of those who I
was unable to get to. But I can assure you,
if I have anything to say about it, and I
believe I do. We will take calls again and I
will speak to you next week, but we'll just going
to take a quick break and then the show continues